good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy thursday i hope
everyone's having a gorgeous day we are
because jackie's here it's merch day
it's show day and theo's here and theo's
here so it's obviously gorgeous but i
would say you know actually it's such a
big day because obviously merch day
holiday merch launch this morning we
love seeing you guys getting all of your
tings everything is still in stock
except the two beanies so head over to
shopmorningtoast.com to get your holiday
tings whether it's for yourself or
someone you love we've got ornaments
earmuffs robes jackie and i are both
wearing two we didn't even plan this
again so we are actually like inverted
you know we are
simpatico
hypnotico
[Music]
we are wearing two different parts of a
matching set i'm obviously wearing the
crew neck in an xl and jackie's wearing
the pants yes these are the white sherpa
pants claudia's wearing white shirt crew
neck i'm wearing the pants in medium i
do wear them below the bump since they
are a medium and everything that i wear
in the merch is medium except for that
sweatshirt that i wore yesterday same
i'm extra large and this sherpa set has
two little patches one on the breast
that says tmt and the same patch on the
leg on the thigh i hope you guys can see
it don't don't overextend yourself i i
really really can't um plus i don't want
to disrupt the dew i'm just now today
i'm feeling wary about how much visuals
we do because yesterday's youtube
catastrophe yeah you guys we're we
apologize for the episode being up on
youtube super super late and then i have
to do have to take responsibility
okay so basically yesterday's youtube
episode when we went to put it up live
like the whole thing had this crazy
static over it like impossible to even
for the whole video so we had to wait
for the video to process we downloaded
it and then we put the podcast audio on
top of it easy peasy so i lined it up at
the very beginning good morning
millennials and our words are matching
perfectly right i didn't think i had to
watch the whole video it's simple
mathematics right but i was watching the
episode yesterday and it goes like in
and out of
sinking and not sinking which is just so
weird because it's the same timing no i
refuse like i don't understand how it
makes any sense yeah but it all worked
out so hopefully we have a regular
episode today and you guys can see our
cute outfits and how we really just
complement each other even though we
didn't plan it whatsoever and how do is
here looking so handsome he hasn't been
to the office in so long and he's here
to put in the work but as always like
our podcast episodes are premium
groundbreaking revolutionary yes throw
it up give birth to it put it in a
blender
um
so that's that's really what's most
important you know this is just for us
this is where the girl is this is for
the girlies and so is the holiday march
so head over to shopmorningtoast.com to
get your tings it's a very exciting day
plus i would be rdh if i didn't also
mention that it's first show day yeah
it's first show day and i'm i feel like
i've gone through like a wave of
emotions this week and now i'm at the
point where like i feel really really
confident in my material like yay
i think it might be better than my first
show like there's so many i you know so
many weird things happened to me this
year it's just i think that it's going
to be great now my concern is like the
memorization of it all like okay and i
think i get a lot of questions always
like about how do i memorize like when
you write something and it's like a part
of your life like it becomes a part of
you but when you get so nervous like
when you're on stage like
you might as well be like
out there with nothing right and i
assume tonight like you'll have your
notes and you might have to glance over
at them and you know the more you do it
the more you'll get off book that's why
i'm doing these city winery shows like
for me they're really just dress
rehearsals but i always want to give
people like the best possible yeah real
show so for the audience it's so raw
yeah so i am gonna be if you're coming
tonight like we're gonna have the best
time i will have some material on stage
just in case like i wanna you know be
prepared i think that's totally fine i'm
so excited for you i'm so glad that
you've got your groove back and you're
feeling your comedy because you should
i'm just i'm so nervous like i'm telling
you i think we should do the show late
tomorrow like after i complete the show
and if it's a success like i will be out
at until 6am celebrating like the wave
of relief that has washed over me okay
we could definitely look into pushing
the show back that works for me in my
schedule you know what i love about you
it works for bruce schedule too you know
what i love about you i never have to
think twice about like well jackie be
annoyed if i want to push back the show
yeah no and you're so easy on the
contrary as well it when you do need to
move it up i make that work yeah but see
what
now with such unbridled enthusiasm no
what the annoying co-hosts giveth the
annoying co-host take it away like if i
have to make a flight i'm like we film
early i know that's your least favorite
thing so i try and give and give and
take you know yeah yeah no i mean it is
what it is but if you if you do what you
got to do it's tonight is about you so
well i'm excited to see everyone and
it's gonna be fun i heard the food at
city winery is so good like i'm thinking
about going early and having dinner a
hundred percent maybe take some home
tomorrow
literally that's a really great plan um
so yeah i've been really really busy
doing that so i have not watched any tv
this week so sorry the tv recaps have
been totally off that includes last
night i just was rehearsing my show for
anyone who would listen via facetime
well last night only winter house was on
i didn't watch it i've given up on
winter house you have yeah because um
once i learned that patron craig like do
not fall in love on the show it's not
worth it i had to leave and i'm sorry
but like the house and the kitchen like
it just gives me anxiety and i'm too
honestly like i'm and i don't want to
say old because i'm not that old but
like you're not i'm just in a mature
phase of my life mature than that fridge
i agree like when i see that fridge and
then i see you i just think these two
things are not simpatico yeah or like
just like it's just chaotic in there and
i just can't relate to any of it like
the
ex
drinking and like it's just a lot so the
only thing that i like was living for
was paige's fashion and she posted put
pictures to her instagram so i i feel
satiated i am still gonna watch it even
though i am currently two episodes
behind i've just like
i've been in a funk and i will get back
and also like because you haven't been
watching it but no one else has been
like you have to watch oh my god it's
the craziest thing ever no that's true
you know yeah it's not like a it's it's
not like i can't miss yeah i think it's
just like if you if these are some of
your favorite reality tv stars it's like
fun to see them all together yeah you
know i was reading my book last night
rock paper scissors it's like this
thriller but slow burn it's pretty
spooky honestly
so spooky but it's good and i'm in it
and
that's all you can ask for out of a book
it's so all you can ask for
i completely agree
um
i have been on this really weird journey
i got a pr box from ollie like the um
vitamin company yes and i've been taking
i've really been wanting to do hair skin
and nail vitamins and so i was like
excited that they gave it to me because
i'm just so lazy but they also have
these sleep vitamins i've been taking
them every single night they're just
like melatonin i've taken them before
i've been out every night at 10 30. it's
such a joy i wake up before my alarm
it's such a different life i'm like now
i'm thinking like would i rather have
that one hour at night to like watch
tick tocks or the one hour in the
morning just like get my bearings
bearings yeah team bearings i'm like
afraid to keep taking them because i
don't want them to like lose their
efficacy yeah that is what happens
like but just this week i've been so
anxious and that like if i didn't take
them i would have not gone to sleep till
2am because my thoughts
so they have been such a blessing i just
wanted to shout it out like such a
blessing yeah we have them in our house
i haven't taken them like since last
summer but they can you take them i was
going to ask you if you could take them
all pregnant
i haven't looked into it i probably
probably not i wouldn't do that yeah but
um
yeah no but anyways i'm happy for you
thank you it's always nice to find a
good new resource it's always good to
like feel something different you know
oh well that's for sure for sure well i
think without further ado to do we need
to get into everything because because
this
there's like heartbreak much news to
discuss heartbreak but also shipbuilding
season in palm springs so without
further ado it is time for the fast five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
solo stove which is slowly turning into
like one of our most popular sponsors
and everyone's just like waiting with
baited breath for the code so i will
give it to you solo stove is the most
fabulous product there is nothing quite
like feeling like the feeling of
gathering around a warm fire on a cool
evening and the smokeless fire pit from
solo stove makes your outdoor moments
even more memorable because instead of
having to constantly dodge campfire
fumes you can just sit back relax and
actually enjoy the fire with solo stove
and this year you can shop their solo
stove black friday sale early you can
get great deals on the solo stove fire
pit from november 11th through 18th so
that's today make sure you check it out
they're having amazing sales you're
upgrading your backyard with a solo
stove fire pit they're brilliantly
engineered made with premium grade 304
stainless steel and a 360 degree airflow
system that maximizes the efficiency
while minimizing the smoke it's easy to
light with just a few bits of starter
and the fire is blazing in minutes it's
also perfectly portable so you could
take solo stove with you on a camping
trip and more it's really genius um
you were just telling me you were in
vermont and your friend sam had one yeah
and it's like
like i mean obviously sitting around a
fire is always amazing but it's also
especially nice but you don't have to
worry about the cleanup and like the
ashiness and the smoke it's all so
self-contained and it takes the treach
out of fire building shop solo stove's
best deal of the year early from
november 11th through the 18th and get
10 off with the promo code toast plus a
lifetime warranty and free 30-day
returns
that's pretty good get an extra 10 off
the black friday sale at
solostove.com promo code toast
thank you claudia
oh it's a pleasure okay our first story
we're going to start with the good news
okay pete davidson and kim kardashian i
thought you were going to say we're
going to start with the good news
camilla cameo
stop
pete and kim spend his birthday together
amid dating rumors pete davidson rang in
his 28th birthday with rumored new
girlfriend kim kardashian wow what a
time to live in when you can be live
according to new photos shared by public
enemy hype man flavor flav another part
of an amazing sentence the former flavor
of love star shared two pictures of
himself with the pair wednesday just the
just one day after pete's birthday the
trio were joined by kris jenner who
alongside kim and pete was also wearing
brown and black skins loungewear flannel
pajamas which seemed to be like you know
her holiday collection drop and kim and
pete actually did like kind of what we
did where it's like one was wearing the
top she's wearing the pants and he's
wearing the top and i'm just so shook
also this article says flavor flavor 62.
wow and that just also shook me as well
this is a very shook worthy event no yes
and not to make it about myself
but i did remember that i totally forgot
to tell you i met flavor flav this
weekend it was so crazy okay we were at
the wedding we were in the tent it was
so beautiful but i was like of course
getting hot i need to like take a moment
outside and we were like with our two
friends and they're like you want to
smoke a joint i was like you know what
when in los angeles you know people in
l.a love pot so we go outside and we're
at a hotel so it's like we're in like
the main
area of the hotel and there's like a
really sickening bar there i guess that
a lot of celebrities go to and we're
just lighting up you know as kids do and
ben is like oh my that guy's a huge
clock around his neck i'm like what
i'm like ben
is it flavor flav it was so dark outside
i couldn't see anything i'm like
his diamond necklace was just like
shimmering in the moonlight and was it
this necklace
oh the one that pete's wearing because
it was kind of small it wasn't like you
know the school clocks like in the
classroom it was kind of small and ben
was like i'm gonna go tell him i like
his clock i'm like ben you can't just
tell me like it's clock it's flavor
flavor he's like no it's not comes over
and he's like i like your clock and i'm
like are you flavor flav and he was like
yeah i'm like oh my god
then we're asking him a million
questions about his clocks you know he's
like biggest most iconic clock is in the
rock and roll hall of fame that's so
cool it was an iconic evening
he wasn't there at the wedding
that he would re-enter my life a mere
three days later right at chris's palm
springs house with kim and pete i'm okay
so palm springs house is a sanctuary it
has seen everything if the walls could
talk
honestly i think that house arguably has
more to say than the checkered floor
house
yeah just because you know they all they
have all of these like fun events like
anytime they want to do something
special like they go to palm springs but
i'm a little confused by this picture
because
like kim and pete up until this point
it's like are they aren't they but the
fact that they allowed this picture to
be posted like on the one hand it's like
okay he's spending his birthday at her
mom's house like they're obviously
dating why wouldn't like no but see i
disagree it's flavor flav's birthday
right no it's pete's birthday oh
it's pete's birthday 100
yes yes okay because pete and flave are
real close
he thought it was flave's birthday no
it's not
his birthday he chose to spend it at
chris jenner's house i mean wouldn't you
with his new lady love wouldn't you i
know and he's like from new york like he
had to fly cross-country you know and he
doesn't be back by saturday right so he
does snl it's not like he can just jet
off for like weeks at a time he has to
come back every weekend
so i guess this picture like means that
they're really doing it but for some
reason it was giving me the opposite it
was giving you fraudulent vibes it was
just giving me like friend we're [ __ ]
with everyone yeah yeah but you don't
spend your birthday at your rumored
girlfriend's mom's house yeah at your
friend's mom's house yeah so that's why
it's just making me feel conflicted no i
feel that 100 now that you break it
you've broken it down in this way it
doesn't make me feel any more or less
certain about their relationship but
like just something about this picture
and the fact that it was allowed to be
posted just makes me feel like
they're [ __ ] with us you know i
definitely see that i do and just
totally random did you know that rob
kardashian is living in the checkered
floor house like it's his house now how
nice for him i know i saw it on tick
tock i was shook sickening yeah just
just a little added thing i wanted to
add okay um yeah about this i told you
when i saw them they were giving me
fraudulent vibes
and i want to believe it i do but
something's just not
authentic it's not being authentic for
me yeah
i don't i
so i don't know i think that they're
definitely
friends maybe exploring each other but
sexually yes or even maybe not like
maybe it really is a shango vibe where
they're gonna share one kiss and then
realize it's not gonna work out totally
so i don't know like would you she
wouldn't have had chango's birthday
party at her mom's house in palm springs
shingle would have loved that chango was
such a stand-up guy
and i
i do feel like there's definitely some
love lost there maybe that's why she
really can't move on with pedes because
she's still thinking about chango who
wouldn't be thinking i'm stealing about
django
so i'm just
perplexed it's like i want to i want to
believe like i want to fall into this
but it's like i can't get hurt again do
you know what i mean no i know but you
have to let yourself i have to let my
walls down i know and you're so guarded
like this is like an episode of the
bachelor like so carted is there
something you've been through recently
that's yeah kim yay divorce randall and
lala yeah no you've been scarred it's
too much
for one ship builder
but anyways this is this is good news
i'm happy i hope they had a great time
it was also travis's birthday yes this
week courtney got him a car she did
what kind and he's like dream car i
don't know i didn't click and they're in
cabo and they're in cabo with the kids
on the horses cute stunning i didn't
realize she got them a car
they're really cute like i'm very here
for them yes oh for sure
okay now we have to move on to the scn
the sad couple news
shawn mendes and camila cabello break up
sean and camille announced their breakup
wednesday evening on instagram in a
joint statement they posted to their
respective stories same statement
different fonts they said hey guys we've
decided to end our romantic relationship
but our love for another as humans is
stronger than ever
we started our relationship as best
friends and will continue to be best
friends we so appreciate your support
from the beginning and moving forward
love camilla and sean
they didn't say love i added that so
i mean it seems as though claudia's
choking over there so let's just give
her a second are you okay
oh i've been there it's the worst
so
you are happy that they're broken up
because i was i'm actually not i had
come around to them i thought they were
one of like the greatest love stories
well i wouldn't say that no like they
were two
so
talented popular everything celebrities
who like really just like chose each
other chose a low-key life and they were
gonna like they're gonna work and then
they're gonna come home to each other
like it was really quite beautiful and
there were so many like specs rumors and
speculation before when they started
dating that this was like purely pr they
had the song together and they just
outlasted every last rumor like i don't
even remember that time anymore because
to me like they really were like otp and
i actually really thought that like it
was so cool that like they met when they
were both like starting out to become
famous sean obviously became this like
mega global superstar and it was like
always camilla like i actually thought
that was really cute
and why this bothers me is because i was
looking at it on the comments
on e-news everything everyone's like
well now he's gonna come out as gay and
i feel like he's talked about this a lot
and he said like i'm not gay and
everyone thinking that like makes me
like uncomfortable like i don't like
that just bothers me now because i feel
like those rumors have been refueled and
if he does like if he does come out like
i'll you know eat my words but i don't
think he is yeah i mean he said that he
wasn't whatever he wants to do it's his
choice
yeah um
i'm just i'm sad i feel like their
relationship is also like a great role
mod great like role model for their fans
yeah i agree because they were just so
committed to one another they were like
living in florida and like walking the
dogs low-key and like they were always
leaving the house both of them looking
like messy and that's what you need from
celebrities like yeah frizzy hair like
that's what you need it's real like you
go to get iced coffee with your
boyfriend like you're not wearing makeup
yeah and you love to see it they really
did grow on me as a couple and his
documentary um
wonder was like a lot about her even
though i didn't think the documentary
was that great i thought it was really
sweet how like it's always been camilla
every song he's like if you go back and
listen to every song i've ever written
before camilla like it was always about
camilla like i can't write this
song that's not about you and i was like
that's actually really cute this is
making the breakup hurt even more i know
about it and here's the thing who gets
taylor swift in the divorce like they're
both really close with her i want to say
honestly i don't know maybe camilla
maybe but yeah because she's taylor's a
woman who supports other women but they
said in their statement that they're
best friends and they're continuing to
be best friends i mean usually that's
kind of a line but i for some reason i'm
just choosing to believe them yeah like
i feel like there's no bad blood
but i like the taylor swift reference
but what do i know no i know i mean
we'll see how this pans out me too i
think they're both like nice people
yeah
i'm gonna miss them me too like i'm
gonna miss everything they gave us the
good and the bad yeah i think at first
like their energy was so chaotic but
then i got used to it you know and like
even their chaos was so stable for me
yeah no and now it became something you
could rely on yeah and in these times of
like never-ending
chaos and
turbulence it was nice to know that
camille and sean were like always going
to be like on the beach making out like
no one was watching even though everyone
was yep i thought they were a good
couple i agree and i think they were
like good role models for their
audiences yeah but you can't stay
together with someone just because like
you want to be a role model no oh no no
no no you have to be a role model in
your independence
that is gorgeous
are you ready for our next story some
more breakup news if it's the breakup
news that's brought to you by hush your
literal favorite new sponsor my favorite
new sponsor please tell them about it
okay so we've talked about hush a lot
but one of their new products is taking
the toast world by storm
so let's talk about the quality of sleep
the reality is over 160 million
americans struggle with sleep and hush
is here to help they are an
industry-leading sleep brand that
carries a wide range of sleep essentials
for every sleeper whether you're a hot
or cold sleeper hush has what you need
to get the job done they carry anything
from pillows and sheets to their
best-selling weighted blankets and
mattresses which which you know we have
spoken about at length they even have an
iced technology which keeps you cool all
night in their iced weighted blanket and
mattress so if you're looking to improve
your nightly rest hush is the answer
they also have a hundred night guarantee
on all their products you can try it out
for a hundred nights and return it with
no hassle whatsoever but what we're
really jazzed about today here to tell
you is their new silk pillow cases which
is a game changer if you're a person
with hair if you're a person with a face
yeah
wrinkles
like creases in your hair a silk
pillowcase from hush will so alleviate
so many of your morning problems and it
will it's so good for your skin it's
it's so soothing to sleep on i've been
sleeping with these silk pillowcases for
about two weeks now and every time i put
my head to it i'm like thank you hush
thank you thank you um
so they also give back from day one hush
has donated one in ten adult products
and one in five kids products to those
in need around the world so if you're
looking to upgrade your sleep head over
to hushblankets.com they have a huge
black friday sale happening right now so
make sure to check them out before the
sale ends again that's hushblankets.com
to take advantage of their black friday
sale
such a great they also a great gift for
yourself and for others but just like a
silk pillowcases everything in the sort
and hush makes a sickening one no a silk
pillowcase is the best gift also if
you're having a wedding and you're um
leaving like gift baskets in the room a
really thoughtful thing is a silk
pillowcase because people are always
doing their hair for weddings the
rehearsal dinner i think um i just
thought that was a good idea you know
i'm that i actually travel like when i'm
staying somewhere other than my home i
bring my own silk pillowcase you do yeah
because it makes such a difference in
the quality of my sleep yeah and because
if i'm not if i'm using like a scratchy
pillowcase i actually will sleep on my
hand because i'm like get this thing is
your hand like pins and needles when you
wake up yeah well i'll put like my my
pajama arm over it and then just sleep
on my hand but because you just don't
know where these pillowcases are so true
and what they're made of but i actually
always bring a silk pillowcase with me
so it's good to have one you know in
your travel bag yeah just a life hack
next breakup news my unorthodox life
starbot sheva heart and husband ben
weinstein break up the 28 year old
reality star and tick tocker has split
with her real estate agent husband after
more than nine years of marriage a
source close to the family exclusively
confirmed to e news the inside is crazy
the insider told e news that botsheva
who wed weinstein when she was 19 years
old is filing for divorce soon news of
the breakup comes just a month after the
couple's nine-year wedding anniversary
wow though neither acknowledged the
milestone on their instagram this year
botswana didn't celebrate in 2010 oh i
guess we should have known well the
thing is there's so much to unpack here
first i thought the way that it was
announced was so bizarre like e-news
posted it but neither one of them was on
their instagram it's like they were like
released a press release or something
like it was weird yeah but then he
posted not famous anymore but that had
been from the day before nobody thought
anything of the caption until we found
out they were divorced ah so he posted a
picture of himself said not famous
anymore
so i never watched a show but you didn't
no oh okay but i
know enough about their relationship
like from you and just from the press
and like the tenor of the like what they
were going through which was like they
got married when they were both
extremely religious and young and then
over the course of their marriage she
her family like
drew back from the community became and
like like you it's your whole life yeah
and so
of course like for bachelor and her
siblings like if her mom was doing it
like it's easy for them to follow but
like
if you're in laws or like you know like
ben didn't have to leave the community
too but he did but he did but he was
definitely having a harder time you know
like immersing into secular society so
there were a couple things in the show
that like he was struggling with and i
think people gave him a lot of [ __ ] like
because he was worried about like
bachelor transitioning from wearing
skirts to wearing pants and he wasn't
being a dick about it but it's like your
whole life like every girl you've ever
met wears skirts yeah
so
he had like a a hard time with it like
for like a week and they were being so
mean to him in the show and i'm like
give him a second like he's alerting
everything he's ever learned in his
entire life so i mean i think when you
watch the show
like you really rooted for botseva and
ben
um but it's also not surprising it's not
sustainable and
they were to me like they had they had a
chance like they really did
but first of all we talked about this
recently like when you get married so
young like you know you grow up and you
change
this is an extreme of that like you
change your whole life so i think it's
very rare plus on top of that they got
famous so now she's like not only is she
this modern woman but she's a famous
person
all of those things were things he did
not sign up for at 19. right so i think
that like
them being
divorced is the least surprising thing
but it's also a little shocking because
if you watch the show like
bachelor really wanted to make it work
like she still had like a hand in both
worlds she still like kept kosher and
was just doing like what we do like
modern orthodox in secular society um so
i think she was really trying hard to
like make both things work like being
secular her mom's famous having a
netflix show like you're gonna be an
influencer she's a tick talker but then
also like things she grew up with like
keeping kosher wearing skirts so
it's like it's just not sustainable but
you really were rooting for them yeah so
i wonder i mean i guess the place that
they were at during the show you know
she was continuing to grow and so maybe
they grew apart but i wonder if it's
like
she became
more even more secular i think she was
when the sh when the show was filming or
he just decided he couldn't live with it
i think it's the first one because of
all of the changes in their lives
because if she goes to fashion shows
like she's all like you know it's not
just like
i married a girl who's now less
religious it's it's a different world
yeah like people change as they grow up
but this is like such an extreme version
of that it's like i think you were
saying at one point during the show like
they were trying to keep shabbat yeah
and it's like but now you know every
party happens on friday night and it's
yeah it's but he's also you've got he
definitely leaned into like the secular
life too like but it's easier for a guy
like he if you look at him on instagram
like he's fashion like he loves it all
yeah he's a stylist yeah and he just
like went he came to the spritz party
right like he's
really i think he's into it like so i
don't know where things went wrong
because i think at least with the way it
seems like they both had like
they were on the same page in terms of
like
religion and
the new life that they had because of
the netflix show so i'm not sure where
it went wrong i mean i've tried to tell
you yesterday fame changes people it
does and i think that this is a big
factor in this and now like bachelor
could be running around town like with
john mayer imagine you know yeah
so that'll be interesting to see and
this show will probably have a season
two
already started filming okay cool so
we'll find out soon yeah hopefully um we
didn't miss this because i think they've
been filming for quite a minute so um
i'd like very much for this to be a part
of it yeah but i mean even if like they
weren't filming yesterday
the cameras are up the cameras have been
up for the last whatever six months
we'll see like the breaking the
deterioration even though like
when i did watch the show
i wouldn't say it was the most authentic
show like it felt very staged very
scripted like these are real people and
these are their real circumstances but
the scenarios in which they were putting
themselves in were hella manipulated so
i hope one of my requests for the second
season is we get more of like an
authentic reality show yeah that makes
sense because even like selling like a
lot of the netflix shows feel that way
like they're obviously very um not
scripted but set up but i think like
selling sunset does an amazing job of
like you would never know like that
they're not like working full-time real
estate agents you know yeah but there's
like none of these things would ever
happen if there weren't cameras there
right because none of these people would
choose to get together right
okay our next story some exciting
casting news the crown cast its prince
william
and he will be played by dominic west's
son
enough dominic west is playing charles
charles and so his son in real life will
be playing how old is william like a
baby no this is like uh tween 13 years
old his son is 13 years old also like
when diana dies
yeah and it's towards the end of the
season he'll be in like the last few
episodes and he's like coming of age as
he because he's like blonde like they
were blonde into a young man yeah this
um the variety article doesn't have a
picture of him but i thought i saw one
yesterday and maybe it was dominick
west's son maybe his name is cena well i
don't know how to pronounce it
s-e-n-a-n
oh the kid you know
he's got it cinnamon doesn't not look
like william i'm not when he was a kid
william was so cute when he was a kid
there's not a lot of pictures of him on
the internet like literally there's one
picture of dominic west and his entire
family like from a trolls event like
that's cute but this must have been a
few years ago because the kid looks
really young but he does have the same
like shaggy blonde hair it's not a
terrible casting i just like personally
i've had enough of dominic west oh we
know
we know but it's enough and so have i um
but i having just watched made this idea
that like
no
no
no but andy
mcdowell and her daughter play mother
daughter the chemistry is unmatched the
chemistry it's just like a cute factoid
about the show and and i'm here for it
it's a little nepotistic but
yeah what are other examples i like the
only example like miley and billy ray
yes and that was
chef's kiss heavyweights
ben stiller's dad is like the former
camp owner they don't play father and
son but they're both in the movie okay
no but like when
we're like they
i mean we have sister sister
one of the best franchises of all time
yeah cowbells without actually actually
actually recently watched sister sister
did i tell you that
no you didn't it was on a plane or maybe
it was on disney plus i can't remember
it was so good yeah those were the days
and you know disney and those
nickelodeon franchises like they really
leaned into the siblings like they loved
that ali and aj cowbells yes yes and
also the one um
with hillary and hailey duff where
they're like
they're they're sisters they're sisters
i think then that then they're like out
on the streets from nada to prada no
that's camilla belle
that was a good movie from prada tanata
but it's the same prada tanata like
story 5. material girls
so good yeah we need more sister duos in
films we need more sister duos in films
and if we had a movie what would like
the premise be you're like good at that
like uh if it was like a that genre
cowbell literally okay so it would be
like cowboys proud of tanata but it
would be like exactly our story of just
like we're doing this show and it's like
so great and then we get canceled and
then we get cancelled and we have to
change our attitude and we like have to
buy a farm like we have no work
opportunities left so we gather all the
money we have left and we like we're
done with this life we buy a farm which
has always really been our dream oh no i
was going to say it and then the true
story like where we we do our own show
and it's like no no i think there needs
to be a farm
okay okay so a and a chairman as well of
course so maybe are we two single gals
in the movie are we married
because i think it's really adds to show
like we both end up falling in love with
like the hands you know got it okay so i
think we we need to escape so we get out
to a farm oh and then we never come back
yeah and then from there we rebuild our
show right so we have like a really
embarrassing moment on the show that
goes viral in the internet we're
completely canceled we're so embarrassed
we're like you know what
my friend has a place on a farm she's
offering to let us go we spend time
there we're having so much fun we found
out the farm next door is for sale and
we're like are we really going to do
this and then we're like going through
the old shed in the farm and we find
like a studio a picture of our dab no
different we find a microphone we find a
microphone like wait we can do it from
here
and then and then we fall in love and
then like we get to live our like
continue to do what we love which really
is the podcast we have this like renewed
perspective on life and we're like
removed you know from the toxicity of
new york city yeah that sounds good what
would the name be
cowbells farm gem and gals no it would
be called like
broadcast like
the broadcast barn
i like that
that's good
the broadcast bar and like the picture
would be like us in a bar and like
holding microphones like
like we're so annoying and like we're
like disheveled yeah like you came from
the big city one knee is like turned in
it sounds like such a good movie free
idea free you have to cast us that's how
it works oh yeah it's not free it has
two large baggages two big strings
attached heavy blow bearing straight
attached yeah
oh
good time
good times
okay are you ready for our fifth and
final story only bits of in the final
story that's brought to you by third
love with third love comfort is always a
given and the holidays can be hectic
stressful or downright uncomfortable so
this holiday season give the gift of
comfort with third love your one stop
shop for all the women in your life
so you can give the gift of comfort they
have ultra soft loungewear for mom fun
sleepwear sets for your sister premium
activewear for your friends and luck's
intimate sets for that special someone
so i'm gonna be gifting jackie a luxe
intimate set
okay third love is one of our favorite
sponsors one of the ogs you guys know we
are two big breasted women and third
love is just a brand that caters to
women who have normal boobs like i have
big boobs i have one boob that's bigger
than the other i have shoulder pain back
pain and third love is just the best
brand their intimates are the best also
all the other products they offer the
best but i really love the bras um
because they fit so well so they obsess
over each stitch you never have to think
about how something feels looks or fits
while trends come and go third love has
always stayed true to one notion they do
comfort we do we
so third love brings the comfort from
the sheets to the streets with the
softest sleepwear luxe washable silk and
bras that you won't want to take off
when you get home they have ninety
thousand five star reviews that do not
lie the bras are available in a half
cups which nobody else has and the
underwear lounge we're in activewear
goes from extra small to 3x
the quiz that you take for the fitting
for the bras is like super detailed and
you end up with like the perfect bra
size and i feel like a lot of the
problem when i used to shop for a bras
was that i never knew what size i
actually was until i went to third love
they are also the largest donor of
undergarments in the us they've donated
over 40 million dollars worth of bras to
help people in need so you just feel
good knowing that your bra fits well and
you're also spending money on a good
cause feeling is believing upgrade to
everyday pieces that love your body as
much as you do right now you can get 20
off your first order at thirdlove.com
toast that's 20 off at thirdlove.com
toast now jackie to answer your prior
question
yes i am ready for
the final story
[Music]
okay
a little bachelor news hannah brown says
she's hooked up with ex peter webber as
his bachelor season aired this book is
like
t failed i feel like there hasn't been a
bachelor book this juicy since andy
dorfman yeah uh
yeah i have to think back because a lot
of bachelor contestants who choose to
write their stories like really just
focus on like their personal growth
journeys and not like the tea that we
which is boring yeah right so so far
we're getting a lot from this book one
she says that she hooked up with peter
webber as his um
season was airing she said they crossed
paths at an engagement party for
bachelor paradise stars dylan and hannah
in february 2020. the following month
fans would learn he got engaged to
hannah and but then broke off their
engagement uh and hannah had told people
that
she heard that they were having trouble
but hannah brown and peter weber left
the engagement party together so was he
still engaged like was that in real time
was he engaged while it was eric
i don't know so she's saying like she
[ __ ] an engaged man
that is so true she told uh but they did
break up she but they all she also said
they broke up a month after they were
engaged off camera
so then so it's possible that he was
single i just feel like i need some
clarity i think he was single i don't
think she would like you know expose
herself like that yeah i agree but so
she says in her book that they ended up
in bed together that night but she told
people magazine the chemistry just
wasn't there she said it just sucked and
then i found out he had another girl
front runner
maddie on his mind it was all so bizarre
i mean this like we already knew in the
history of bachelors peter webber was
probably the worst bachelor and the
messiest and this is just like
another you know
piece of clothing on the chair yeah and
no and like the craziest part about this
whole story is like okay so he was
getting shanna and he was hooking up
with hannah brown he had maddie on his
mind and he chose kelly
oh yeah
you know
i'm telling you he's so [ __ ] messy he
like after that i i loathed the
franchise he had the best girls yeah
kelsey
kelly uh kelly hannah anne
hannah ann like does not claim the
bachelor franchise anymore though it's
so weird like she's such a big
influencer like on tick tock too yeah
she posted well she posted like a shady
tic talk about this
thing where she uh
lip syncs to the sound that was
embarrassing i really hope you're
embarrassed wow who was she talking to
herself she was talking like she was
talking to the cat like she said when
the t officially spills like about
hannah and peter so this is directed
towards peter yes yes that he should be
that's interesting because i really have
never seen her even like
acknowledge that she was on the bachelor
like you she's like so big on on social
platforms just because she's like so
pretty and spends a lot of time on her
content like she works really hard she's
like a good content creator yeah i've
seen her content and i didn't realize
she was trying to disassociate from i
don't think she's trying i just think
like she's moved on with her life so
completely and she's found like real
work as an influencer yeah and so she'll
never like be on paradise i don't think
something like that that's just the
bible things slow down she'll say that
now that's true everyone says catch her
in two years
you know i mean it's always good to get
like a little boost the booster yeah
in paradise no but like 100 like when
you think like a couple years ago i
never in my life would have imagined
becca kufrin would be on bathroom
paradise and here she is
so it can happen but i do think i mean
it's probably tough but like if you look
at someone like hannah g who was like
the the
belle of the ball in her season
immediately goes to bachelor in paradise
has a fantastic experience everybody
like again bell of the ball and now
she's like
off like in the cannon of biggest
bachelor stars i do think if you over
play your hand and yes and you don't get
the timing right it's sad when you
eventually go on bachelor parties no i
think that
hannah g's experience is the ideal
situation like and i feel like maybe not
enough people talk about that like she
never really got into like any sort of
scandal on the show like she was just
beloved by all the guys she chose dylan
who was like not the obvious choice but
who loved her so much they seemed so
happy they bought a house together
they're engaged she really had like such
an ideal experience she did she had the
same experience as raven she was like
yeah
everybody loved her she went on bachelor
in paradise it's like everybody's dying
to meet this girl she chose adam and
they have a great life together but if
raven or hannah g had like waited
another year or another year to go on
like there are other
girls like younger yeah
that were that are just top of mind no
100 the window is the raven call is so
good the window is small you've got it
you've got to get it right but also
sometimes you could be a fan favorite
and then you go on bachelor in paradise
and all of a sudden you become the
villain like and you ruin everything
that you had worked for and like even if
you're not even trying to be the villain
like you just step in something blake
yeah that's such a good call
paradise is so toxic yeah no but it can
be like
an amazing thing for your career but you
gotta play right yeah and there's really
no way to know if you're playing it
right like they're just gonna decide how
they wanna portray it right so it's just
it's honestly [ __ ] scary i wouldn't
go toxic yeah um well those are the past
five kind of sad like lots of couples
breaking up yeah but you know that is
life such as life and you know couples
need to break up in order for other
couples to get together right that's
true like we have to allocate resources
from one ship to another so maybe soon
we'll be seeing sean and bocheva
together
and camila and ben shiva that's funny
um
camilla ben for sure
that's our show you guys like i mean we
are going to be back in studio tomorrow
but i'm going to be like a different
person like yeah i will have your i
don't know maybe you guys can feel my
energy like i'm feeling kind of like
down today like just because of a lot of
my mind and i think when you see me
tomorrow like i'm going to be much
lighter and we look forward to seeing
you tomorrow we always look forward to
seeing you i always look forward to
seeing you and i always look forward to
seeing you and you always look forward
to seeing you he loves his auntie but
dew doesn't always look forward to
seeing me i mean you know how it is theo
anything you want to add before we wrap
up that he loves the holiday merch
collection i mean did you see brew this
morning cuddled up in my room
he loves this collection so much like
anytime i leave a piece of it like
sitting on the bed or honestly it was on
the floor today um
he just curls up and it's the cutest
sweetest thing so head over to
shopmorningtoast.com for you your loved
one and your pets because it's so cozy
and there's just going to be like a
puddle of love on the floor we have some
really great items they'll start
shipping as soon as possible so you will
have them in time for the holidays
yes i just want to let you guys know we
are close to selling out of the pink
pajama set like relatively soon that's i
think that's not surprising i don't want
to play favorites ooh the ornaments
there's literally only 20 ornaments left
oh gosh so if you made it to the end of
this episode like congratulations
congratulations get an ornament um hold
on let me keep looking both the beanies
are sold out
but there's still stuff left there's
still some left my crew neck is on its
last leg as well so just go to
shopmorningtoast.com
we're wearing i'm wearing extra large
and pretty much everything the robes
just come in small medium or large extra
large obviously i'm wearing the large i
was wearing small slash medium i love
that robe i love the pajamas so much
like they're gonna change my life no
like holiday season is quaking quaking
and now it officially tis the season
should we cap it off with a song yeah
you know it's been a while
tis the season to be jolly fa la
la
la
[Music]
okay now it's officially the holiday
season guys put your trees up get your
toastmart shopmorningtoast.com
have a spritz spritzsociety.com
come to my show girl with no job.com
tour and if you can't make it but you
want to cuddle up with a nice read girl
with no job.com
and then head over to the redheads where
you can listen to a podcast episode all
about the book and then get more
inspiration for other books you should
reach then you can read them and then
listen to the episode and feel like
you're with your gal pals 100
and that's our show thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning toast
the millennial morning show where we
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know every monday through friday
on youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so it's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i heart
radio cast box all the places
so wherever you listen to podcasts find
us the morning shows and leave a
five-star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are and if you
made it to the end of this episode
congratulations and thank you for being
a real toaster who actually values what
we say um so to let us know a signal of
your appreciation that you actually
listened to the end of this episode last
night with holiday emojis i was gonna
say the same thing go to our most recent
instagram and drop as many holiday
emojis as you can whether that's the
menorah the christmas tree the twinkly
lights anything anything that gives you
the holiday spirit a bowl of chili
whatever anything that reminds you santa
claus like any of it love you guys so
much have a great day and i'll see you
tomorrow